We'll wait for another couple of
minutes and then we'll get
started, yeah.
Hi, good morning.
Yeah, you can just put it as
100% per head, yeah.
If all of them have equally
contributed, then you can put
100% for all of them.
So in general, how are things?
Have you taken any resolutions?
Yeah.
The way we are two slides will
be attached to the same
announcement, yeah.
I was maybe not too, by the way,
did you all get a chance to
attend it?
And yeah, for a change.
What I've done is I've given you
a chance to unmute yourself
today.
Yeah, just to try it out.
So I request all of you to stay
on mute in between after every
concept.
Or so I will.
You know, give you a chance.
And at that time you can unmute
yourself, yeah.
OK, OK.
Yeah, I would do that.
Yeah, they don't worry about
that.
The portions will be everything
that we cover till the last
class that is the next class.
Yeah.
So today we are in the seventh
session and the next session
will be the next weekend, which
is the 8th class and whatever we
cover till that day will be the
portions.
But don't worry about that.
I will also be posting an
announcement after that class.
I'll also be discussing with the
other section professor, and we
will, you know, put a complete
announcement on the syllabus and
then resource wise I have
iterated this several times,
which is go over and above.
The first thing would be your
recordings.
Your PT, your class notes, and
so on, and then the next step
would be your textbooks
reference books and then the
third step would be above that
right, which is practice.
Some Internet questions, past
papers and so on.
I'll also be uploading the past
paper after the next session,
yeah.
There's another question my
query, especially in case uh,
no.
For PS questions, please post it
in the discussion.
I'll not be answering those in
the classes.
There's a dedicated thread
created for all the problem
statements.
If it's problem statement eight,
you would have to just go there
and ask your question and if you
have already done that and if
you have not got your answer, it
will be done today, yeah.
And if you have any assumptions
and so on while solving the
problem, state all of them very
clearly in the document that you
prepare.
Yeah.
So that is 1 bundle of a
deliverable.
Your code as well as your
explanations, whatever
assumptions you have made.
If you just call it out in your
report, then it'll be evaluated
accordingly, yeah.
Cool.
I think it's good time for us to
get started, so let's quickly
get started.
So welcome to the 7th contact
vision for data structures and
algorithm design and what we
will be doing today is we will
continue with graph.
We will see graph traversals and
so on, and then we will move on
to another important concept
called BST.
Yeah.
So most of you attended the last
class, So what did we do in the
last class?
Real quick, yeah.
What exactly did we do in the
last class?
Three is in graphs.
Yeah.
Was it really trees?
But was it a special tree?
Yeah, giving you hints it was
not trees.
It was a special tree, which is
nothing but heaps, right?
So we completed heaps.
We had seen some examples of or
applications of heaps with.
There's nothing but heapsort and
priority queues, and then we got
started with this new concept of
graphs, and we learned about
what exactly is a graph and you
know what is the terminologies
involved in it?
Right.
And then a lot of you know,
types of graphs, right?
Simple graph paths and all that.
And finally, we had also seen
this whole topic of how do you
represent a graph, right?
We'll quickly have a recap of
that.
Also, there was one more
technique which was pending, so
we will complete that and then
we will go for traversals.
Yeah.
Adjacency matrix.
Is that clear for everyone?
It's a very simple technique
where you use a matrix right
where you use a matrix to
represent your graph.
The number of rows and number of
columns in the graph will be
exactly equal to the number of
nodes, right?
So how many nodes are there in
this graph?
Yeah, 5 notes.
Why notes?
Yeah.
So here you have 5 cross five
matrix right?
Simple as that.
So for any given graph, when you
want to denote it in the
representation of a system, you
will use N cross N matrix.
So that simply means that our
matrix will always be here
square matrix, right?
It will always be N cross north
and inside that if there is a
particular edge from V1 to V2,
you will put it as a one.
Otherwise you'll put it as a
zero, and so on, and rarely.
What you can also do is if there
are multiple edges.
So in this case, from V5 to V2,
there are three edges, so we can
count that as three, and we can
also denote it as.
So we 2 to V5 as three and V5 to
V2 is also three.
So it taken some examples like
these and we also told that if
it is a undirected graph like
this, right?
So there are no directions here.
It's an undirected graph for an
undirected graph, the matrix
will always look symmetric,
right?
If you just imagine you put a
line on this principal diagonal,
and if you fold this matrix
right, it'll be symmetric.
So this one will overlap this
one.
This zero will overlap this
zero.
This one will overlap this one
this three with this three
right, so it is symmetric in
nature.
So just by looking at a matrix
you will get to know if it is
the matrix of her undirected
graph or a directed graph,
right?
So is this clear for all of you
real quick?
That.
Can you explain it to me one
more time was not clear much.
Yeah.
Which part is not clear.
How do you this matrix was
defined based on this graph?
OK, real quick, let's do this.
I again urge you.
Please watch recordings of the
last classes we had completed
all this long back.
So let's take another graph.
You have ABC and let's say from
A to B you have an edge and from
B to C you have an edge and from
A to C also you have an edge.
It's a very small directed
graph.
If you want to represent it in a
matrix, then the number of nodes
here are three, so you'll take
ABC.
You again take here ABC.
Is there it's going from A to a?
No.
So it's a zero.
What about B2B?
No.
What about C2C?
No.
So put it as zero from A to B.
There is an edge going right
from A to B.
There is an edge here, so A to B
will put it as a one from A to C
also there is a edge here, so
we'll pull it as a one.
What about B2A for B2A?
There is no edge going there, so
B2A0 from B to C yes, there is
this edge, so it is the one from
C from see, you don't have any
age going to a nor to B.
So these two are zeros, so this
is the representation of this
graph.
If at all you have parallel
edges right, for example, you
have one more edge from A to B,
then you can count it as there
are two edges here.
So here you can represent the
test.
Yeah.
Is this clear now for all of you
the same way you can represent
it for undirected edges.
Also right N cross N matrix,
just put it as zeros or ones if
at all there are parallel edges,
count it and put it in the
metrics.
So what are the advantages and
disadvantages of this?
Yes, Sir, this is clear.
But one thing I not need to ask
you here.
When you gave the example, it
was pretty easy to understand
because there was a directed
graph like.
The arrows are when you say
directed graph it is you mean
Right.
the arrows, right?
Correct.
Yeah.
Correct.
But becomes little bit difficult
to understand.
So if it is not even having
arrows, what does it really
mean?
It simply means that you can go
from V1 to V2.
You can go from V2 to V1, right?
So in both those cells you will
have one.
So let me redraw this graph ABC
and let's draw the same thing
again.
Something like this, right?
This is what you have and if you
want to draw the metrics for
this right you have ABC.
You have ABC now the whole
scenario changes right from A to
a, B to BC, to C to zero again,
right?
Because there is no edges from A
to a like the self loop from A
to B, there is a edge which
means you can go from A to B and
you can come from B to a also.
So A to B becomes A1B2A also
becomes A1.
Similarly, from A to C, there is
age so which simply means you
can go from A to C as well as
from C2A.
So from A to C it is A1 from
C2AL, so it is A1.
Similarly from B2C from B to C
and C2B, this is the matrix for
undirected graph.
Yeah, all good simple stuff.
Thanks.
Yeah.
Ohh I'd tell no but but then the
given example, right?
Yeah. Thanks.
So only the diagonal will be 0
or should be one, right?
The given example here equal to
01001.
No, not at all, right.
For example, the first one just
try to name these.
This is we want this is V2.
This is V3.
This is V4.
This is V5.
This is V1.
This is V2.
This is V3.
This is V4.
This is V5 right?
So in this case the diagonals
are zero, no problem, but from
V1 to V3 also V3 that it is a
zero.
Why is that?
Because in the graph from V1 to
V3 I don't have an edge.
Do I have edge going here?
No.
So that is also zero from V1 to
V4.
There is no edge, so that is
also zero.
Ah, no thank you.
Right, so all the edges alone we
should consider. Right?
Cool.
I believe now this is, you know,
pretty clear if there's a graph
given you should be able to
translate it into a matrix.
If a matrix is given, you should
be able to translate it back
into a graph.
Great.
You'll just, you know, put the
number of nodes and then
wherever there is a one, you
will try to add edge wherever
there is a zero, you will not
add an edge.
You'll be able to reconstruct
the graph back, right?
So the very first advantage is
it is very fast to tell whether
an edge exists between two
vertices or not, because it's
very simple.
In this example, I want to know
if we four is connected to V2,
right?
All that I'll have to do is go
to V4.
There is the V2.
I'll take this cell if that is a
zero.
It means that they don't have a
connection right.
There is no edge between them.
If it is a one, it means there
is a edge between them, so it is
very fast to tell me whether
there is a edge existing between
two vertices or not.
It's as simple as going and
inspecting the matrix for a one
or a zero.
It's very easy to, but what
other disadvantages?
It consumes a lot of memory on
sparse graphs, right?
So what really is a sparse graph
now?
So there are two types of
graphs.
Yeah, sparse graph and dense
graphs.
So sparse graph is the one with
only few edges right?
For example, let's assume I have
N is equal to 100.
What is it?
The number of nodes.
Yeah, I have 100 nodes in my
graph, right?
But let's assume I have only 45
or 50 edges, right?
I have connected something like
this.
Only few edges.
I have not many edges I have so
such a graph is called as a
sparse graph where you have a
lot of nodes, but you have only
few edges.
On the other hand, there is a
concept called dense graph where
you have a lot more edges than
the number of nodes, right?
For example same example, you
have 100 nodes, right?
But you have 200 edges right?
In that case, what can you
comment about that graph?
What will be more in that graph?
I have under notes I have 200
edges.
Then what does it really mean?
What type of edges are more?
Yeah, exactly.
Krishna is bang on.
That is parallel edges, so all
of these are connected.
Apart from that I also have
parallel edges, meaning from the
same node I have, you know,
extra things going on.
That is why there are a lot more
edges than the number of nodes,
so lines are more than the
circles, right?
If you draw such a graph, that
is called as a dense graph,
right?
So we will learn about these
when the time comes in the later
part of the semester as well.
So in some use cases we might
want to have a sparse graph
right?
For example, Internet
connectivity in all your towns
or cities, wherever you live,
your Internet service provider
might want to just connect all
the houses.
They will not have a lot of
extra cabling from, you know,
all the other houses like
duplicate cabling.
If one fails, let the other so
they're not going to do that
because each cabling is money,
so they would want to have a
sparse graph, whereas there are
dense graphs.
Also possible, there are some
examples when we'll see later in
this course.
We'll just remember about it,
but what about the sparse graph?
So when you have a sparse graph
like this in our matrix
representation, what would
happen?
There's a lot of nodes, so the
matrix is big, but inside that a
lot of things will be a 0,
right?
So it will be a wastage of
memory meaning a lot of cells
inside the matrix are zeros.
So we are wasting it, right?
Exactly.
So that is a disadvantage if you
have a sparse graph, then this
matrix representation is not
very efficient because anyway
most of the cells are zeros and
also for undirected graphs there
is redundant information right?
Which is exactly what we were
looking at.
So if you look at this matrix,
this lower triangular and upper
is actually the same, only
right?
So this one and this one, this
one and this one, this one and
this one this and this three and
this three, right.
So there is actually duplicate
information.
If you only give me the lower
part or higher part, that's
enough for me.
I already know it.
So basically it means that
whenever you have an undirected
graph, there is extra
information or redundant
information in that matrix that
is also some small disadvantage.
So is the matrix representation
clear?
But in case of self loop, yeah,
in case of self loop you will
also have a one there.
Yeah, in the diagonals also you
will have one.
Specifically for 100 Node 200
Edge graph, is it not necessary
that it has parallel lines
right?
Connecting the nodes completely
itself will take hundred.
Yeah, that's also correct.
Yeah, if you have completely
connected also that will be
having more than 100 edges and
that is also dense graph.
Cool.
That being said, is there any
doubts for adjacency matrix?
We'll keep doing this.
Don't don't worry about it.
As the course progresses, we'll
keep creating such, you know,
matrix representation for a
graph, right?
How many number of nodes are
there?
Create that many number of North
Cross end matrix.
If there is an edge between two
nodes, put it as A1.
If there is no edge, put it as a
0, right?
So now what about that last
technique?
Right, which is called adjacency
list.
There's a lot of extra
information here which you can
read offline, but I'll quickly
tell you what this is about.
Yeah, it's a very simple
concept.
Again, all of you, yeah.
Real quick.
So what type of graph is this?
Yeah, woment.
When someone asked you like
this, what type of graph is
this?
This is her undirected graph,
right?
It doesn't have any arrows, so
it is an undirected graph
involving how many nodes it has
seven nodes, so it is an
undirected graph with seven
nodes.
Perfect.
So in this adjacency list
representation what we do is
firstly we go ahead and we
create an array.
We create an array of N
elements, right?
So in this case, how many
elements are there?
How many nodes are there?
Seven.
So I'll create an array.
This is that array.
This is that array with N
elements and this is nothing but
N nodes.
Done.
You named it with the node names
which is 1234567.
Now the next step is you go
ahead and pick up each node.
So I pick one wall, are adjacent
to one.
Yeah, we all are directly
connected to one or adjacent to
one.
Who are they?
Who is connected?
Five is connected, six is
connected.
So for 2/5 and six, go ahead and
create a link list node.
Yeah, you learned about linked
list.
Please remember that you'll
create a node.
You will create a pointer,
right?
So you created a node for two.
You create a node for file.
You created a node for six.
You joined them and this whole
list you joined it to one.
So how do you now read this?
So the way to read this, the
correct representation is one is
connected to two, one is
connected to five, one is
connected to six.
It does not mean two and five
are connected.
Five and six are connected.
Yeah, a lot of newbies make this
mistake.
Don't make that.
I'll again repeat this very
small concept.
Pick a node.
Yeah, for example, you go ahead
and pick three.
All are adjacent to 3/3 is
connected to two.
Please connected to four so
create a linked list using these
two elements.
Either you can create it as two
which then points to four, or it
is your representation.
You can also have four first
then which is pointing to two,
the cruxes for whatever nodes
are there.
Go ahead and create the nodes
and now join that to the actual
node that you're inspecting, so
you are in three.
So join that there two and four.
So this order doesn't matter
because the way you are
interpreting this is 3 is
connected to two and three is
connected to four.
There is no relation between
these things.
Yeah, a lot of students will
believe you have one is also
connected to five.
Four is connected to five.
Five is connected to two no.
How do you read the last line?
The correct way to read the last
line is 7 is connected to four
and seven is connected to five
and seven is connected to two.
Yeah.
Is this representation clear for
all of you?
This could have been the other
way.
Also, seven is connected to say
first node was two, then you had
five, then you had four.
Any form is fine.
Yeah.
Is this clear?
Guys, all of you very simple
concept.
First create an array with an
elements, right name them.
As you know, each of those
nodes, then for each of those
nodes see who all are adjacent
to him, who all are connected
directly to it.
For those elements, create a
linked list and attach it to our
array element.
Simple stuff.
Yeah, this is called the
adjacency list representation.
What are the advantages of it?
New nodes can be added easily
because all that we are doing is
just creating a linked list for
it and attaching it.
New notes can be connected with
existing nodes.
Yeah.
Again, the same concept.
Who are my neighbors can easily
be answered correct, because all
that I'll have to do is say
suppose I want to know who all
our neighbors to fight or who
all are connected to file
directly.
All that I'll have to do is I'll
have to come to that particular
element in the array.
I'll have to just traverse its
connected linked list.
That will tell me who all are
adjacent to me. Right?
That's very simple for me.
That's also an advantage.
There's some questions if there
is, uh.
Directional then link list will
have uh elements in the
directionally.
No, that that also is and you
know order doesn't matter.
The same concept holds good even
if this graph was, you know,
directed or undirected, it
doesn't matter, you will just
see who all are connected to
this one right, irrespective of
it.
You will take those elements and
you will put them in the linked
list, right?
But you will just see who all
are.
Adjacent meaning who all are
going from that one, right.
Not the ones that are coming in
and so on, right?
Only the outward you will
consider, right?
But what are the disadvantages
here?
Yeah, there is one pages
determining whether an edge
exists between two nodes or not.
Yeah, I ask you a question.
In this graph, you'll have to
tell me if five is connected to
two or not.
So what will be our approach?
Will first go to that five
right?
And if five is connected to two,
then there will be a link list
with the node 2, correct?
That is what I'm looking for.
I'll take this address.
I'll go there.
It's six.
It is not two, so I'll take the
address.
I'll go.
Here it is one it is not two.
So again I traverse again.
I traverse finally at this.
This is the end of the list, but
I did not see two, so at this
moment is when I can conclude
that five is not connected to
two, meaning 5 doesn't have an
edge to two.
So what is the complexity here?
In a matrix, all that I could
have done is I'll go to that
five.
I'll go to this too.
I'll see what is it value there?
If it was a one, there is an
edge.
If it does a zero, there is no
edge between them.
But here I had to go take that
element and traverse the whole
linked list.
So traversing a linked list,
what is the complexity?
No, it is not in square.
Yeah, real quick.
Yeah, it is.
Yeah, that's right.
So which is bad?
Yeah.
Whereas in a matrix that was big
of one, I can directly go check
that cell, it'll give me the
answer.
But here I'll have to just go
through the whole linked list
and let's say suppose there is a
node which is connected to all
the other edges right?
So it means that that's the
worst case, right?
So one node will be connected to
all the other nodes in the
linked list, so that is nothing
but traversing and elements
which is big O of N cool simple
stuff.
Yeah, I have given a lot of
exercises.
The excises have already gone in
the last class slides.
Yeah.
So please practice them.
Yes, no, the exercises are
nothing.
OK.
But I've given you a list,
you'll have to convert it into a
graph.
I've given a graph.
You'll have to convert it into a
matrix just by looking at a
matrix.
You should say if it is
directed, undirected and so on.
Yeah.
So if you have no questions,
please mute yourself and we will
proceed.
Yeah, so far, so good.
All of you for parallel
vertices.
Will there be a duplicate list?
Yes, exactly.
There will be a duplicate one
for parallel.
Yeah, inside this link list you
will have again one more there,
yeah.
Cool.
That being said, now what all do
you know?
You know what is a graph?
Graph is a set of you know nodes
vertices.
You know how it was created.
The applications of it and a lot
of terminologies, right?
What is degree?
What is, you know, subgraph?
What is a cut edge cut vertex?
A lot of adjacency and you know
those technologies and you also
know how to represent a graph
using matrix and adjacency list.
So now you we will look at
traversals, right?
So what are the different ways
to traverse a tree?
You also told the webinar was
good, yeah.
The inorder, postorder,
preorder.
Exactly.
Yeah, there are three ways to
traverse.
Mainly for a tree which is in
order postorder and preorder.
So similarly, what we can also
do for a graph is there are two
ways which is breadth first
search and depth first search
the name has the word search.
But don't get confused.
It is just a traversal
technique, but it is not just a
traversal technique.
It can be used for many other
applications also, yeah, but
what exactly is traversal?
Traversal is nothing but walking
through our data structure
exactly once.
Yeah, if there's an array you go
about printing all the elements.
That is traversal.
You have a queue.
You go from friend to last.
Yeah, that is nothing but a
traversal and so on.
So what exactly is BFS now?
So we'll look at both of them
complexity wise.
Both of them are the same, but
these two are two techniques
similar to your preorder
postorder.
In order, all of them have the
same complexity, but they're
philosophies are different.
They need in order.
You did something in preorder.
You did something right.
Similarly, these two are the
same complexity, but their
ideologies are different.
So let's look at BFS.
First, Bradford search is a
general technique for traversing
a graph.
BFS traversal of a graph G
visits all the vertices and
edges of G determines whether G
is connected.
Correct.
Because if there is a graph
which is say something like
this.
Yeah, you start with this node.
You go visit the visit.
There's there's all this.
You've completed it, but even
now there is a node which has
not been visited.
So what does that mean?
That means that this graph is
disconnected, so it determines
whether G is connected or not,
and then computes the connected
components of G.
So whatever you had traversed,
that is nothing but the
connected components.
Whatever you are not able to
reach, those are the
disconnected components.
Computes a spanning forest of.
Yeah, this is for you to
explore.
There is no good explanation on
this in your text.
Explain about other tests so BF
is on a graph with N vertices
and M edges because they may not
be the same.
Right edges can be more or edges
can be less.
So overall the complexity will
be big off n + m time.
Yeah.
And BFS can be further extended
to solve other graph problems.
Yeah, this is a normal technique
just to go ahead and traverse
the graph, but just by doing
that or just tweaking it a
little, yeah, by adding some one
or two lines of extra code we
will be able to do something
extra.
What is that we can find and
report a path with the minimum
number of edges between 2
vertices in that big graph.
I give you 2 nodes.
I tell you from these two nodes
what is the minimum number of
edges to reach them?
Yeah, BFS will be able to do
that.
Yeah.
Find a simple cycle if there is
one.
Yeah.
Cycle.
You guys know you start from a
node.
You go all the way around and
come back to that node.
That is a cycle, so if there is
a cycle, BFS will also be able
to detect that it'll be able to
tell you so a lot more things it
can do.
Yeah, I'll leave it to you to
explore all that, but we will
just look at the BFS actual
traversal and all these
applications are clearly given
in the text, even with
explanation and the pseudo
codes.
Now, how do we do that?
Yeah.
How do we do this BFS right?
So BFS is typically known as
breakfast.
So what we do is we use a queue.
Yeah, it is very common to use a
queue to keep track of the nodes
to be visited next, and the
nodes that have been already
visited.
Yeah, because it's a graph,
right?
There are many nodes there, so
we will use a queue to keep
track of wall have been already
visited and who all are yet to
be visited and typically use of
a queue leads to a breadth first
visit order, breadth first visit
order is cautious that is very
important.
It is very cautious in the sense
that it examines every path of
length I before going to all the
paths of length I + 1.
Yeah.
We will see about DFS also, but
in DFS it is more cautious.
It's very vigilant.
It doesn't go deep into a node
and so on.
It examines all the length I and
then goes to the next level I +
1, and so on, and in this whole
ecosystem, once you draw this
BFS, you will have something
called as a dotted line which is
called Cross Edge and there is
something called a solid line
which is called Discovery Edge.
We will draw that and at that
time it will be one more clear.
Yeah.
Well, let's look at this all of
you.
I want you to focus 200% because
this is the only slide I have
for BFS.
There's a lot of animations.
I'll repeat this, but just
listen to me.
Yeah.
First things first, there will
be a question in your mind.
Can I have multiple output for
BFS?
Yeah.
What do you think?
A graph like this is given to
you.
Yeah, it is an undirected graph
here.
Can there be multiple answers
for BFS?
Yes, right.
So when says yes and that's
correct, because BFS itself
simply means traversal.
Yeah, maybe similar starts from
one sheet, traverses the whole
graph with one.
Maybe Krishna starts from 5
right?
Or, you know, PATHAK starts from
8, right.
So it depends on where you
start, how you go.
Ultimately, you'll have to visit
all of them that are possible,
so the outputs will be
different.
OK.
That being said, then how do we
maintain consistency, if at all?
Such a question comes in exam.
You will all take your own
notes.
You'll do your own traversals,
but how do we evaluate it?
Yeah.
So there is an unsaid
convention.
Yeah, there is a.
That is a convention, not a
rule, right?
It is that we will always follow
numerical or alphabetical
ordering.
Meaning, if there is a graph
given to us which is having
numbers then we will always
start with one or zero whatever
right?
We will start with that and go
proceed with the graph.
If it is with numericals or I
mean alphabets, you will start
with a.
He's that clear for all of you.
This is not a rule.
And so on.
Yeah, you can start with any
node.
You will get your own output,
but just to stay consistent most
of the time what we will do is
we will use ordering right in
this graph Amit.
We will start with one.
We will start the whole
traversal with one.
If there is a graph with ABCD
and so on, you will start with a
right.
You will not start with some
other random nodes because that
will give you an answer which is
correct.
But to maintain consistency, we
will always start with one, and
if there's a graph with ABCD,
we'll start with a in the
question.
Also, it will be clearly given
to you.
Yeah, in many times it will be
given like, you know, start with
this node.
Then you'll have to start with
that, or it'll be told that
follow alphabetical ordering.
Then you should start with a
well.
So in this graph this is again
BFS and DFS.
Both are traversal techniques,
so it can be applicable to both
directed and undirected graphs,
right?
We will take example of
undirected.
Here, directed also is exactly
the same.
We'll start with one.
Just see the steps that I'm
doing.
Yeah.
And Mark it in a different
color, meaning I'm now in one.
Yeah, I have now reached one.
I'll enqueue him into the queue.
I'll put him in the output.
What all did I do?
Yeah, let's take it slow and
simple.
But once you get a hang of it,
it's very simple.
Yeah, I first landed in a note.
I changed this color.
I enqueued him into my queue,
right?
I also put him in my output.
That is all I have done so far.
Now, who is there in my queue?
One is they didn't make you.
And what is the front of the
queue?
Yeah.
Before concept in a queue there
is friend there is last year one
is the friend, so remove him.
Remove the front of the queue.
Whoever is there in the front,
remove him and explore him.
We explore.
I mean, look at who all are
connected to it.
Alright, let's do that.
Remove that one.
See who all are adjacent to one
that was called as exploring
that node, exploring one.
So who all are adjacent to one?
You will tell me?
To entry.
Very good.
So two and three are there.
So again, numerical ordering,
you should not do 3/2.
That's not wrong, but you will
mention it as two comma three
change their colors, add them
into the queue, add them into
the output and this arrow
doesn't mean I'm converting an
undirected graph to directed
graph and so on.
It simply indicates that I have
come to two from one.
I've come to three from one.
Yeah, a lot of authors don't do
that.
You can just put a normal
without arrow also and that is
also correct.
Yeah, this is not meaning.
I'm converting it into directed
and so on.
It simply means when I'm
visiting the notes from where
did I come from?
One I came to two from one.
I came to three.
That is what it means.
Yeah, so far, so good.
What we did, we visited a node
or we landed in a node, right?
We changed his color.
We added him into the queue and
we added him into the output and
in this whole output was two and
three there before.
So in this state, there's only
one, and now 2-3 have come for
the first time, meaning for the
very first time I saw two and
three, so that is called as a
discovery edge.
So very for the first time I'm
discovering 2 and three, so
these edges are solid lines.
Solid line means discovery edge.
Yeah.
And I've also put these two in
the queue.
So now who is in the front of
queue?
Two and three are there.
So who is in the front of queue?
Yeah, always.
This part is the friend, right?
So two is there in the front and
here you have the last right.
So now I will have to explore
two meaning just carefully look
at it.
I deleted that too and I'm
exploring him, meaning I'll see
who all are connected to.
Two.
Who all are connected to two?
Yeah, real quick.
Waller, adjacent to two very
careful.
Yeah, Simran is right.
All of them which are connected.
You should have a close look.
One is also connected.
Three is also connected.
Four is also connected.
Five is also connected.
You see this line for right from
two there are four nodes that
are connected.
No one is already there in my
output and from one to two there
is already a discovery edge
also, so do nothing.
Three is also already there in
the output, but between two and
three there is no edge in my
output.
So what should I be drawing?
So Amay visiting 3 for the first
time or is 3 already there in
the output?
Please already there in the
output.
I know about the existence of
three when I was at one itself
right from one, I already
detected that three was there.
So from two to three, should I
be putting a solid line or
should I be putting a dotted
line?
Dotted solid.
Yeah, exactly.
No, not solid because three is
already there in the output,
right?
So when there is something
already there in the output, you
will not be putting a solid
line.
You will put a dotted line,
meaning it is already there in
the output.
I'm not discovering him for the
first time.
He's extra there, but what about
four and five?
Four and five are not even there
in the output I am discovering
them for the first time via this
to only from 2 only.
I got to know the two is
connected to some node called 4
from 2 there is something called
file.
So for them I will have a solid
line.
Firstly 4 and five I added into
the queue.
I changed their color, I put
them in the output.
So as we discussed from two to
four two to five, it is a solid
line but from two to three it is
a dotted line.
So far so good.
What is the next step?
Who will be explore next?
4.
Yeah.
Is it?
Be.
Look at the queue.
Yeah, we should not have random
answers.
We should follow the same step
in that queue.
We have been exploring from the
front so one got explored, then
We.
two got explored.
Pay.
Now 3, right, we will remove the
three.
Now I removed it.
I'll ask myself the same
question.
Who?
All our adjacent to three I
should list down.
All of them adjacent to three.
Who are they?
12578 out of that this is 125
are already there in my output,
right?
But seven and eight are not
there, so seven and eight.
I should change their color.
I should enqueue them here.
I should also put them in the
output, but let's explore the
other part and what type of
edges will it have from 3:00 to
7:00 and 3:00 to 8:00.
Will it be a dotted line or will
it be a solid line because seven
and eight are not even there in
the output for the very first
time?
I'm looking at it.
I'm discovering them from three.
It should be a solid line.
I didn't.
Perfect.
But what about the others?
SO12 and five were already there
in the output from one to three.
There is already a solid line
here.
Solid edge here, so do nothing
from two to three.
Also, there is already a cross
edge or dotted line, so do
nothing but from three to five
there is nothing right, but five
is already there in the output.
So what edge will it be?
It will be a dotted 1, right?
See the output now.
So what we have done now you
have changed seven and eight
color.
We have added them into the
queue.
We have added them in the output
from 3 to 7328.
It was a solid line from three
to five.
It was a dotted line because
five was already there in the
output via 2 right now.
Who's the friend of the queue?
He's 4, so I'll explore four.
One question, sorry three to
one.
Yeah, go ahead.
It's like a unit.
I mean, it's a it mentioned as a
unidirectional right, but it's a
bidirectional.
So don't do mention a dotted
line for 3/2.
No, that is what again and again
I'm repeating the arrow doesn't
here mean that I'm converting
that graph to a directed graph,
it just indicates I came from
one to three or I detected 3
when I was at one.
That was all it means.
If this is failing, confusing,
don't use the arrows.
Just put solid lines here, yeah.
But.
Well, so whenever you see
something which is already there
in the output and with the
exploring node, if you don't
have any connection then it will
be a dotted line. Right?
Yeah.
Amit from 3 to one there is no
dotted because there is already
a line existing there.
If there is already a edge
between them, don't do anything.
Don't add extra dotted lines or
you know things like that or
another tip for you in this
final output, there will not be
any parallel edges, right?
Every two nodes will have only
either a solid or across.
You should not have multiple
lines.
Who?
Let's finish this problem.
We'll come back again.
So now the front is 4, so
explore him.
Delete him.
I deleted him.
Explore 4 exploring.
I mean, who all are connected to
four, so two and five are
connected two and five.
Both are there in my output.
Right, there is nothing new and
from two to four or four to two,
there is already some edge also
solid edge.
So do nothing from four to five.
What type of edge should I put?
Will it be dotted or solid?
Yeah.
Real quick, very good.
That's it.
I did not explore anyone newly
so I could not add anything to
the queue of it.
Now, who is the next note in the
queue?
These five.
So delete five and explore him.
By exploring I mean who all are
connected to five all are
connected, two is connected,
three is connected, four is
connected, six is connected, but
234 all of them are already
there in the output.
But just check from five to
three.
There is already some cross edge
from 5 to 2.
There's already edge from four
to five, so there is an edge.
Don't look at directions.
There are already some edges, so
do nothing, but six is not even
there in the output, so I am
discovering him from the first
time, so five to six you will
have a solid line.
You'll put six.
You'll change his color, you
will enqueue him into the queue.
Yeah.
What is the next step?
Who's there in the front of
queue 7?
Remove him and explore him.
Seven is connected to three and
eight. The innate.
Both are in the output from 7 to
three.
There is already an edge, but
from 7 to 8 there is no edge
there.
So from 7 to 8 you will put a
dotted ones that what is the
next step 8 is there.
So remove eight, they might
explore him.
Who all are connected to it?
Seven and three.
Both of them are there in the
output and both of them also
have some edges to 8, so do
nothing.
Last node 6, remove him.
Explore him.
Six is only connected to five
that is already there in the
output.
There is also an edge between
them, so do nothing.
So now my queue is empty right
when my queue is empty.
My problem is over and you all
remember in what order we
removed things from the queue.
He usually one got removed, then
two got removed, then three got
removed because remember that
order.
12345786 yeah, yeah, of course.
It's before, but that exact
order, right we removed first
one, then 2345, then 786.
You remember right that is
called the BFS traversal output,
and this resultant whatever we
got is called as a BFS spanning
tree, and in that all the dotted
ones are called cross edges,
right?
Is this part clear for all of
you?
There is a very, very
systematic, you know, way to
solve this problem.
By steps you did right, you
started from a node.
You change this color, you put
him onto the output you added
him into the queue.
These steps once you add things
to the queues you started
deleting from the front, you
deleted one node at a time.
Once you deleted him, you asked
yourself who all are connected
or adjacent to that node and all
those notes you inspected?
Are they there in my output
already?
If it is not there, you will add
it.
You'll also put a solid line or
a discovery edge and you will
add that into your queue if
those nodes are already there.
In my output, it means that
edges are extra.
You already know those nodes are
there, so you will put a dotted
line and you will not add them
again and again in the queue.
Correct.
This is a very systematic way to
do, but let's also quickly look
at your textbook way.
Yeah.
So there's a graph given.
There are some color devotions,
meaning initially the low color
and blue color.
You know nodes, these nodes all
are unexploded.
Once I visit someone, I will
change Ms this red color, you
know background with Violet
initially all of them are
unexplored.
Once I discover something, I'll
use this red color discovery
edge dotted 1 red green.
In this graph, Amit will tell me
where will I start the
traversal.
Nothing is given here.
If there is nothing given, what
is the answered convention?
But where should I start this?
Yeah, I should start from a.
Yeah, I'll start it from me.
I've finished day from a where
will I go?
Yeah, I'm now going to explore a
meaning wall or adjacent to a
from a I know that B is there.
That is why I've changed it to
discovery from a.
What else do I know?
What else is connected to a?
See is also connected.
D is also connected right?
And then will be the next node
to be explored.
In other words, in our example,
deleting him from the queue and
then seeing wall are connected
to it.
Very good.
B.
Right.
I'll remove B and I'll ask all
are connected to B.
So from B to C it will become
dotted, right?
Because C is already visited but
BE to E is not visited right?
So I'll change B to E discovery,
and then who's the next node?
I'll explore I'll explore C so
when I remove C and I'll explore
him, see to D will become
dotted.
C to E will become dotted, but
what about C2F?
Yeah.
C2D became dotted.
C to E became dotted, C2F became
solid, and the next step I will
remove D then D2F will also
become dotted and that is my
final traversal.
When I'm removing ENF there will
be nothing right, because
already both the edges are
either discovery or cross then
there is no new node that I can
discover from them.
So my traversal is over.
Yeah, go ahead.
This is also the same thing
guys, but it is a different way
of representing.
That's pretty much, yeah.
Yeah, I have it out here.
So why do consider a or?
Yeah, go ahead.
Why not B?
Because we don't know what is
level 0 and level one, it can be
horizontal or vertical.
So can't we consider the height
of a graph and which is having
Exactly right. Yeah.
the maximum height of that node
should be considered as a root
and then traverse from there?
Yeah, hello.
So in the simple way, there's a
graph have a root, no right?
You.
No.
A graph doesn't have a root, so
technically you can start from
Yeah, yeah.
any node.
You can start the traversal from
EFC Abd anywhere you can start,
but as I told in the initial
part of this session, it is an
Umm.
unsaid convention.
It is not a rule.
If you start from B and do the
traversal, nobody will tell it
is wrong, but you will get a
different answer.
Everyone will get different
different answers based on where
they start the traversal, so we
have an answered convention that
always start from alphabetical
ordering, right?
If it's the graph with ABCD,
start with a.
OK.
If it's with numbers, start with
one.
OK.
Good, but you can also try that.
Yeah.
If you start from, you will
still get the you know solution
that is a different traversal
output.
Pull the seudo code of it real
quick.
This is also really simple.
Yeah, initially, what did we do?
We have Q as a queue.
We keep inserting our elements
into that queue.
We have Q.
We keep inserting our message.
Ah, someone is not muted all and
whenever we visit someone, we
mark it as visited and until
that queue is not empty.
Oops.
Who's that?
I'm still hearing echo.
How can you please mute?
Yeah.
What we do is we will then try
to dequeue someone and we will
check his neighbors, right?
We keep doing that until my
queue becomes empty, right?
My complexity would be because
we bless E yeah.
Is this clear?
Guys all of you BF first
traversal.
Yes.
No, maybe which approach was
easy this textbook way.
Another quick question, like if
there's a node already in the
queue, then we'll put the dotted
line simple right?
Exactly. Simple.
Yeah, that's right.
So we have to check the queue
again next time.
If we are traversing and then
see if that element already
there, then put a dotted line
and if there's a line only exist
Correct.
then do nothing.
No, nothing.
Yeah, exactly.
Non textbook ways easy, it seems
OK yeah.
Anything that you prefer that
should be fine.
Yeah, as long as you understood
it's good.
So as I already told BFS
Applications BFS is just a
traversal technique, but if you
just add some small lines of
code to him, he's a powerful
technique.
You will be able to solve other
types of problems also, right?
So they're all good design
exercises.
Try to do them first.
Try to solve it yourself, right?
The same BFS, how can I use it
to detect a cycle in my graph?
Try to do that and if you are
not able to then go ahead and
look at the book right in the
text.
As I told, there is already
clear explanation for all this.
You can go ahead and give it a
shot.
Yeah, pull.
Now let's go to DFS.
Can we do BFS and no, no, you
cannot do all that.
Yeah.
Lifo is what lethal is.
Which concept?
Last in first out is what.
Last in first out this your
stack you should always use a
Step talk.
few in order to do your BFS
right.
You should not be using a stack.
If you use a stack, what you
will end up getting is a DFS.
Yeah, that is the next slide.
Yeah, so far, so good.
Let's go to DFS.
Well, again, depth first
traversal is a traversing
technique and again it can do
all the things that BF is also
does.
Yeah.
And the offers on a graph is
again the same complexity.
He can also be used for the same
extended problems, like for
example.
He can also do you know if
there's a path between 2 there's
a cycle or not, et cetera.
Yeah.
So it is very common to use a
stack to keep track of nodes
visited and nodes that I've
already visited in order to get
there TFs depth first visit
order is aggressive in the sense
that it examines complete paths,
right?
It is very aggressive in nature.
How was BFS?
You guys remember that word that
we use there?
My shoes.
Yeah, very good.
It was cautious.
We're very cautious in that
nature.
We don't want to be very
aggressive level by level.
The moment you explore a node,
you see who all are adjacent to
it, right?
And consider all of them and so
on.
But here we are going to go very
aggressive.
For example, if you have.
Oops, I will just try to take
this.
In your childhood.
Have you played this type of a
game where there's a food here
and there is a mouse here and
you need to get him reach the
foot?
Have you played this game?
The maze game.
Yes.
Yeah, you will start with this
and you will, you know, start
going somehow.
You know, you keep going
somewhere, you get blocked, and
when you get blocked, what do
you do?
You come back and see.
OK, I made a mistake here.
Maybe I should have taken this
path and somehow you will keep
doing that to reach that food,
right?
This is called DFS.
You catch hold of 1 path you go
as deep as possible.
Somewhere you know that you are
stuck.
You cannot go any further then
you take a step back and take
another path.
Annoyingly, you learned DFS.
Yeah, this is what is DFS.
We'll see that with the graph
and it'll be even more clear.
But what did you actually do?
You were aggressive the moment
you saw one path.
You believed that it was going
to take you to the foot.
You kept on going in that path
aggressively.
You did not consider all the
other paths right?
That is why DFS is aggressive.
Same concept here.
Here also you have Discovery
Edge that is using solid lines.
Here also you have dotted lines,
but here it is called as back
edge it is not called as cross.
OK, let's do that.
In this case, let's do it on a
directed graph, but here also
you can do it undirected.
Also, it's the same concept.
Yeah, consider this graph below
and perform DFS with D as start
node.
Yeah, we should be very careful,
Jagdish.
In this case, we have been told
where to start.
If we have not been told, then
we can use alphabetical
ordering, but here it's been
told so we will start from
there.
I have a visitor array.
I also have a stack.
Yeah.
Just listen to me.
What we're going to do you start
with a node that has been given
to us.
Change the color.
Put him in the output.
Mark him as visited.
Pushing onto the stack now who's
the stack top?
Have pushed him onto the stack
there.
Yeah.
Is there in the stack top?
I asked myself now D is the
stack top.
Where all can D take me.
We're all can detect me.
They can take me to see decan
take me to YFD can take me to E
Yep, not.
right.
It has three edges from D to
CD2FD2E it yeah.
Hello.
And now again, alphabetical
ordering.
I can either go to F or CORE,
but since we are following
alphabetical ordering we will go
to CI, go to see my changes
color, I mark him as visited, I
push him onto the stack.
Now my stack top is CI ask
myself where can C take me?
Where can she take me?
Check the nature of the graph
and then tell me can see even
take me anywhere, nowhere.
Right.
This is where that puzzle
problem right?
You got stuck somewhere.
No, it cannot take you to F
Amit.
Yeah.
Be very careful, this is a
directed graph from FI can go to
C but from CI cannot go to F
right?
So it cannot take me anywhere.
I'm stuck there similar to that
maze problem where you got stuck
at that point.
What you did, you take one step
back.
You use your eraser, you go back
and then take another path,
right?
Similarly, here we are going to
now pop that see from my stack.
No nodes adjacent to see,
meaning cannot continue.
So backtrack that is, pop the
stack and restore the previous
data.
So I'll remove that.
See, I'm back to D now.
No, we're all can detect me.
He could have taken me to CFE.
But see, I have already visited
it can either take me to FRE
between F&E alphabetical
ordering.
I'll go to the path.
I'll mark him as visited.
I change this color, I put them
in the output.
I push him on to the stack.
Now stack top is E I'll ask
myself where all can E take me?
Where can he take me?
Is only one place which he can
take me.
He can take me to G so go there,
change his color, admin the
output, mark them as visited,
push them onto the stack.
Now stack top is G where all can
G take me.
G can take me to D as well as H
but D is already in a different
color, meaning it's been already
marked as visited.
So what will happen to this G2D?
Can someone tell me what type of
age should I book there?
D is already there in the
output.
I've already visited him.
Cross edge.
Yeah, very good.
That's nothing but dotted and in
this use case, when we are in
DFS that is not called Cross
Edge.
That is called a back edge.
In BFS world it is called cross.
In DFS world, it is called back,
but it is the same concept, so
I'm not going to take it because
it's again going to take me to D
only, which I don't want to do.
So I'm still at G only.
Where else can geotech me you
can take me now too H.
So I'll change this color.
I'll mark him as visited.
I'll put him in the output.
I'll push him onto the stack.
No stack top is edge, so we're
all can hedge.
Take me, which can take me to
A&B, but because of
It won't be.
alphabetical ordering, I'll go
to a.
I change this color, I put them
in the output.
I marked them as visited in my
array.
I also pushed them onto the
stack.
Now stack top is a where all can
a take me can only take me to B.
So I go to BI change this color,
I mark them as visited.
I put them in the output.
I push him into the stack.
What is the stack top B where
all can B take me?
Yeah, it all can be.
Take me now.
No where.
So what should I do?
I'm stuck now.
I cannot go anywhere now, so I
will do.
I will pop him.
I'll remove.
I'll come back to state A can I
take me anywhere?
Apart from BB's already visited
so again a also cannot take me
anywhere, so I'll pop a.
Also, I'm back to hedge.
Hitch would have taken me to A
or BI had initially taken that
route a I could have taken B
also, but now that B is already
visited, So what will happen to
this particular edge?
He weighs, know it dotted,
perfect again.
Remove hatch also because
nowhere else he can take me.
I'm back to GG.
Could have taken me to H which I
have already taken with solid G
could have taken me to D that's
already dotted nowhere else.
You can take me.
So I'll pop G also.
Again, I'm back to E where can
he take me?
You can only take me to G, which
I had already taken, so we
cannot take me anywhere else.
I'll poppy also come back to D
is there anywhere else that D
can take me?
Yes, you can take me to F so
I'll go to F I'll change this
color.
I'll mark him as visited.
I'll push him onto the stack.
Where can F take me if can take
me to see, but she is already
marked as visited.
So F2C becomes dotted and then
anywhere else can you take me?
No.
So I'll remove F.
Also, I'm back to D&D, take
me anywhere else.
He he's also done right.
He cannot take me anywhere else,
so I removed D also and my stack
is empty.
That simply means my depth first
traversal is completed and this
is my DFS output.
Yeah.
Is this clear? Yeah.
SO11 quick question if there is
a solid line then also we're
putting the dotted line in this
DFS, but it was not the case in
No, no.
the BFS like F2C.
Actually, what we are doing is,
uh, in that case I was drawing a
new output right?
In this case I have just altered
the same existing graph.
That is why it looked to you
like that.
Yeah, you'll get it right.
OK, I'm good.
If you solve this like how we
did for BFS, if you draw a new
output right when D is visited,
you add him.
Umm.
Then from G you order dotted,
otherwise you add a solid, so
Got it.
you will get the same output.
Uh, OK.
Yeah.
Well, is the concept clear guys?
What all did you do?
You changed someone's color, you
marked them as visited.
You put them in the output, you
push them onto the stack.
Over is in the stack top.
You ask yourself, where else can
you take you?
You keep doing it when he's not
there, you will.
He cannot take you anywhere.
You will pop him.
You'll go back to the previous
state.
Yeah, so far, so good.
All of you DFS.
Now there is a small twist here.
Yeah, in this problem I tell you
to start the whole problem using
alphabetical ordering.
I tell you, do the whole
traversal, but start it from the
node a yeah, if you start from
the node A, how will this
problem behave?
I start with a I mark him as
visited.
Yeah, I push him onto the stack.
This is the output, yeah, from
a.
Where else you can take me?
He can only take me to BI, mark
him as visited in the output.
I push him onto the stack from
BI cannot go anywhere, so I pop
B and again I'm back to a.
He cannot take me anywhere.
I remove a.
Also stack became empty and this
is my only output.
Yeah, the man was right.
Only AB.
That's only the output.
99% of students will leave it
here, and that is a mistake
because fundamentally, by
definition, a traversal is
something where you are visiting
all the nodes.
But in this case you have not
been able to visit.
Yeah, only B is then output.
The stack became already empty.
Yeah.
Is this problem clear for all of
you?
Yes.
No.
If you start with the node which
cannot take you to all the
nodes, this problem will happen.
Yeah.
And you will get some partial
output here and then you are
done.
Your stack is already empty, so
in those cases you should write
a line telling that if I start
this traversal with a, I will
only be able to reach A&B.
So then what you would do is you
will then continue this problem
by taking some other node as the
starting node.
Yeah, exactly.
Yeah, you will take some other
node again now.
Yeah, let's assume you will take
C or DEV or H or D whatever, and
then you will try to continue
this problem.
It's no, you'll keep doing like
that until you have visited all
Ohh.
of them.
I said I actually I didn't got
the intuition which you have
Yeah, go ahead.
So the.
said at the last statement.
Like once our stacked is got
empty.
So what is the point of
relevance for putting a NP again
in the stack and returning it as
output?
I didn't got this point.
No, we are not putting it in the
stack.
So similar to here, I was just
putting the output here.
Once you removed BNA, that's it.
The stack is empty and as per
our original definition, when a
OK.
stack is empty, your traversal
is done, so you believe it is
Correction.
done, but have you actually
covered all the end nodes?
In this graph there is a
BCDEFGH, but in your output
OK.
there is only A&B, right?
So you have not been able to
visit all the nodes when you
OK, Sir.
started your traversal with a.
So at that time you should not
just leave it there.
Yeah.
So then you should try with some
other node.
Maybe you'll start with H as the
starting node or you will start
with G or you will start with D
and then you will try.
If you are able to achieve if
nothing is possible, then you
will visit each one of them
alone and you will put an output
right?
So A/B will be a separate output
comma.
Then you start with some other
node.
Let's suppose C from.
See, you cannot go anywhere.
So see alone becomes the output,
and then you start with some
other node.
Say you know D, so from D you
will be able to go to others.
Something like that.
So all that I'm trying to say is
let's assume there is a a very
simple use case for you.
There is this exact graph and
then there is this part.
This whole thing is 1 graph now.
Yeah, you started D you got all
the output.
Yeah, you got this.
Have you still completed the
traversal?
Because P&Q are not there in
your output, but your stack is
I.
already empty.
So in this case you should not
leave the problem here.
You should again tell that what
will you tell.
In this case you will tell if I
start from DI will not be able
to reach some nodes because the
graph itself is like that,
right?
This graph is a disconnected
graph.
I cannot reach PNQ at all.
So you will tell that line and
again you will start this
problem with P or Q as the
starting node and then you will
add them again in the output.
Yeah.
Or let's say suppose this was
connected like this.
Will you still be able to reach
P if you had started the problem
from D, you would have not.
Yeah, your whole problem will
get completed, but you could
have not gone to PRQ right?
So in that case also I'll
mention that line that if we
start from D I'll not be able to
visit all nodes and then start
the problem again from some
other node start from P so
you'll get P&Q as your
outputs.
So this whole thing in simple
the crux is if there are N nodes
in your graph, nodes should be
there in your output.
We don't bother if it's
disconnected, connected.
Can I go to a node or not all
that?
Finally, the output should have
all of them.
If you are not able to go to
some nodes, then again you'll
have to retry with some other
node.
Yeah.
Got it, Sir.
Is this clear guys?
Thank you.
No problem.
Uh, so one question here.
Yeah, yeah.
In the DFS we will get the nodes
connected with the arrow, right?
Corrected with arrow meaning.
Connecting.
Yeah, the like D is connected to
F but D is going to F right?
Like in BFS, there is no arrow,
it's only vector row parallel
rows parallel line. Sorry.
You mean our example?
Yeah, yeah, yes.
So that was just an example.
Yeah.
You, yes.
So you can have arrows in this
graph and you can still do BFS
also in that and DFS also yeah.
Yeah, I I got it said.
But in DFS we will get only rows
not this vector, right?
So which vector you mean?
Sorry like like one is connected
to two correct and two is also
Correct credit.
connected to one in BFS.
But in DFS, if the row is
corrected then that means he's
one is connected to two, right?
Yeah, correct.
We can.
For example, if there's an arrow
here, it means one is connected
to two, but two is not connected
to one, so you cannot go that
way.
Yeah.
OK.
That's it.
Yeah, that's correct.
Yeah, well, now let's go to.
Thank you, Sir.
Soon I have one question.
Yeah, go ahead.
So in terms of BFS and DFS, the
discovery edges are helping us
to find the path, but what is
the significance of the cross?
Correct.
Edges are back edges.
I mean in terms of application,
why are we even identifying them
and listing down in terms of use
case application wise?
Is there any significance
advantage for it?
Because the solid lines helping
us to find the path and what is
Umm OK.
the significance of dotted
lines?
What?
How it helps us?
Maybe the duplicacy we can omit?
Exactly.
Yeah, short answer is you have
to find that out.
But in simple if you think about
in the other terms are these
dotted lines actually helping or
contributing in the graph
traversal?
Are they even need it for this
graph?
Yeah.
I think on those terms, if I
start from B, I'm able to visit
all of them even without these
dotted lines, right?
So if all these nodes are some
we know houses and if these
lines are some you know cabling,
I don't need these extras,
right?
So cross edges are back edges is
helping me determine what is
Right.
actually not needed.
If you had started this graph in
some other fashion, to traverse
some other nodes would have
become duplicate, but you are
still able to know that some
nodes some edges are not taking
you to some newer places.
So why do you even need it so
that nodes can be determined?
Yeah, but there is more to it.
OK.
So I will recommend you to read
more about what is backage what
is Cross Edge.
There are some theorems on it
and so on.
So you can try to, you know,
explore about them.
Sure.
Thank you for you.
Yeah.
And we will explore more about
these in the later part of the
course because later part what
we will do in all these arrows,
we will start putting some
numbers.
Yeah, that is nothing but the
cost from going to this place to
this course.
Let's suppose this is the fair
or.
This is the kilometer.
So in those cases, these dotted
edges, et cetera will become
very important.
I would always want to make the
largest cost to be a dotted line
so that I can use the, you know,
minimum and all that.
But yeah, when the time comes,
we will look at all that.
But is DFS clear for all of you?
So I got a doubt here.
Yeah.
So you you did mention about the
maze as example right for DFS,
Correct.
right?
Correct. Yeah.
If you see the ordered node that
where visited right DC e.g.
HABF this has been not been
connected in the no same order
right with the arrow, right D2C
and D2 E that's fine.
Right.
Then it goes to G.
Right. So.
Right.
Yeah.
No, no.
The maze part is only partially
applicable here.
For example this you know from D
to E from E2G and from G to H
and from GH2A from A to B.
Then you are stuck right?
Then what do you do?
Then you come back to a, then
you come back to H then this
becomes cross.
So that's philosophy.
Wise this is DFS you mean right?
OK, alright, good.
You you go hit a endpoint when
you are not able to go any
further.
Even in this case, right?
D2C you went from D to C, but
from C you could not go
anywhere, so you came back to D
again.
You came back to D and then went
to E, right?
Alright, got you.
That concept is the maze
concept, yeah.
Got you.
Thank you.
And if we start from a in this
case will not get the connected
spanning tree for our DFS,
right?
Correct.
Yeah, you will not get it.
So you'll not just leave it
there.
You will then start with another
node.
Books.
Yeah.
So so one more question, if
there is a there is another node
P which is directed from the B
node.
OK.
And now we went to from H2A and
2B and then P when we come back
from H again and we're traveling
to the we, we should not go to
Correct.
the P Now because we are.
Yeah, we should not go because P
already visited. Correct.
Yes, OK.
Yeah.
That's why we have this visited
array for you.
So if that is already ticked, we
will not go there.
Yep, we would have already got
ticked there. How?
I.
OK.
Chips.
I said one question here.
Thank you.
Suppose if I started with a OK,
I can travel still be only OK,
Yeah.
OK, correct.
so now A/B.
So now A/B came in my stack and
I again that put out from the
stack and I have gone to now are
two other note.
Correct.
So uh AB will be come in the
visited node, right?
Correct.
B alone will come.
Yeah.
Nothing else can come, so here
you will have something like a.
You'll have B and then A/B will
be visited.
Nothing else.
So you can again pop B Pop A so
you you are now stuck.
There's only two in the output,
so at that place you have to
OK.
start again with some other
node.
Right.
But A/B will be still in the uh
order node visited right?
Correct.
That will be visited.
That will be half OK. OK.
Yeah, these two are already
visited.
You are only pending with these,
so you can either start with CD
or whatever and complete them,
but in the output already
A&B are there, meaning
visitor is already there.
OK, OK.
Yeah, cool.
Next step, your textbook way
exactly same notations.
This is unexplored.
This Violet color means visited
normal blue line is unexplored.
This is discovery.
This is dotted his baggage.
So initially you start from a,
you go to B.
Let's assume for a minute if we
were doing BFS then from a where
you would have gone, yeah.
From a in this case, I'm going
to B.
If it was BFS, what would have
been the next step?
Where else can he take me?
That is what is a question in
exactly.
Being CD.
It could have taken me to see it
could have taken me to D it
could have taken me to E, but
what is this?
This is DFS to be a physics as
deep as possible.
So the moment I came from A to
BI forget a now, so now I'm
looking at where else can B take
me.
So I'm going from B to C, and
then when I'd say reach C, I'm
asking where else can see take
me so see 2A became dotted and
she will take me to D he took me
to D and I'm at D now from D is
dotted line because it is
already there in output.
So where else can it take me?
It cannot take me anywhere else,
so I come back.
I come back to see right and
from CI go to E and from E this
becomes dotted and my traversal
is over.
So what is the output here?
Initially it was a A took me to
B from BI went to C from C This
became dotted so they took me to
D from D This became dotted it
it could not take me anywhere
else.
So I came back to see and from
see I went to.
That is my DFS output.
If this is complex, don't do it
like this.
Go ahead and try to do like us.
Just have a stack.
Try to do step by step and get
the same answers.
Yeah.
Is it clear?
Days all of you.
So in this case, initially it
was there.
Then we went into the stack,
then see went into the stack.
Yeah.
Then D went in, then D got
popped and then E came in.
Then E also got popped.
He got popped, we got popped, a
got popped.
Yeah, all that is not shown
here.
That is why it is the textbook
way, yeah.
Again, a small code, so I'm not
going through all this because
it's for you to practice.
I will also be uploading a
Python notebook.
There are this is more of a
pseudo code but Python also I
will upload but in simple you
have a stack you push things in
it, you mark it as visited until
that stack is not empty you
remove the top and you see who
are the neighbors of it and you
keep pushing them again into the
stack.
The same thing that we just did,
but it's up to you to trace
every line.
Yeah.
To that again, as I told, if I
just tweak this DFS, add a
couple of more lines, it will be
able to do a lot more things for
us.
All of them are good exercises.
Practice them and compare it
with your text solutions.
Again, there is a lot of excise
questions here.
Yeah.
If I go to the last part of this
deck, yeah, perform BFS and DFS
on the below.
Yeah, there is an undirected
graph.
You should do both BFS and DFS
in this.
Similarly, there is this graph.
You should do both BFS DFS like
these questions.
I love these questions.
There's a graph given to you.
It has been asked to do a BFS
and then tell me which of these
four are they correct output?
Yeah, you can expect these type
of questions in your MCQ's you
will actually do the whole BFS.
BFS you will compare which one
of them is a correct answer.
Yeah.
Are you understanding this
problem in this M has been used
as the start N has been used, Q
has been used, P has been used.
You believe all of them are
correct, correct?
Because traversal wise you can
start from any node like these
question right in this each one
of them have started in
different different start nodes.
So you should verify which of
them is a correct BFS.
Yeah, you be able to do this.
Yeah, you're expected to do this
in one minute.
Yeah, that is why again, tell
you please practice all these
concepts.
There are shortcuts, of course,
but the right way to do is start
from M, do the traversal.
Are you getting this as the
correct one?
If you got it, this is the
correct answer.
Otherwise, go to the next one
and so on.
Yeah, MULAY for this graph.
Implement DFS and BFS traversal.
Assume C to be the source node,
C is here.
Yeah.
Where is C here?
So you will start here end.
You'll try to do it.
Cool.
That's pretty much about BFS and
DFS.
There is a lot more about
graphs.
Yeah.
The moment we have directed
graph right directed graphs, we
have a lot of interesting
questions on who all can be
reached.
Wall cannot be reached.
There's a lot of such concepts.
We will come back to all that
after the mid semester.
Yeah.
And after the midsemester there
was a lot of graph algorithms
also.
Yeah, like shortest path between
two nodes.
How can we go?
Can I have some way to connect
all the nodes but it's total
cost should be minimum?
Yeah, like minimum spanning
tree.
Lot of algorithms are there.
We will learn about it in the
later part of the semester, but
for now we will pause for graphs
and we will start with something
called as BST.
But we'll take a quick break and
then we will start.
I'll be still around.
Yeah, if you have any other
general things we can chat about
it.
The last coexistence, there are
two seats, I believe.
No, that is G, yeah.
T.O.K.
So.
This one right?
So this is C this is G.
OK.
Yeah.
And will tell us about the fact
that So what you mentioned
before.
Which one?
Uh.
You also mentioned that there is
a software to find out the
pathway for X3.
Oh yeah.
I mean the traversal and so on,
right?
Let me just quickly pull that
up.
You see if.
Yeah, just let me know once
you're able to see the browser.
With all due credits, this is
not from bits.
This is from another university.
Yeah.
2nd.
Yeah.
Let me know once you are able to
see this.
Yeah.
So this is, uh, breadth first
search and there is a graph
already given to us.
You can also choose like you
know you want a directed graph
or you want an undirected graph.
You can choose whether you want
a small graph or a large graph.
You put large like.
He'll get a really huge one and
then you can also, you know, put
what representation you need.
Like, do you guys relate to all
this?
We learned all this in the
class, right?
This is that decency list way.
This is the matrix way, right?
Wherever there is a, you know,
representation, there is A1
edge.
Otherwise, it's zero logical is
they have just put the graph
itself.
Yeah.
And then when you want to run
this right, you can change the
animation speed.
I will prefer to keep it
somewhere here and just try to
give the start node.
Yeah, I want to start it from
zero in this case, and if I just
click on run BFS it will slowly
do the animation and it will run
it for you.
Visited it is marking as true
and it is also putting them in
the you know output here it
changes the color.
It's exactly what we did only.
You can alter the speed if you
want even slower.
It'll do it in slower way.
You can alter the speeds and all
you can do it on both type of
graphs or you can have a new
graph every time you refresh you
will get a new graph the I'll
upload all this.
Yeah, it's there in my deck,
Krishna.
So this is for the BFS.
Similarly, you have one for DFS
also.
Yeah, let's try to do some cheap
hacks.
Let's see if that works.
Yes, it does.
Yeah.
So let's start here from, say
one, and let's run DFS.
Yeah.
So always try to, you know,
slower this animation don't have
it very fast.
So slow it and try to do it on
your own.
Yeah.
Then try to, you know, run it
and get your.
If you are getting the same
output or not and so on, right.
Let's say you click on new graph
every time you click on this new
graph button, you will get a new
graph.
Yeah, let's say you got this
graph copied down in a paper.
Try to do it and how we learned.
Yeah, the same pay only try to
do it in our fashion.
Get the output start from the
same node.
Let's say you start from zero,
then give zero as the output.
Here just try to run it and get
the whole answers and then
compare with your answers.
Have you got it correct or not?
They don't use this to solve it.
Yeah, you didn't miss anything.
So folks, we just asking me, are
there some tools?
So there are a lot of animation
tools where you can visualize
these.
You know type of algorithms and
you can see the final outputs.
So I was just showing those
things, but as I told in your
exams and so on, you will not be
able to use the Internet.
So you cannot use these
websites.
So while you learn, it'll be
useful if you are a visual
learner, you know this helps.
Uh, so something like.
Yeah, go ahead.
The yeah.
So, like uh, leaving the
actually choose to start vertex,
we assume that we know all the
nodes or vertices.
That is there like I mean it's
not that we go and OK, OK.
Correct.
Yeah, we we are not assuming we
know that because we have been
You.
given either adjacency list or a
metrics right from there we will
OK.
know how many nodes are there,
correct?
Alright.
So we pick one of them from
that.
Usually we provide the starting
one zero or one whatever.
OK.
Yeah, that that information is
there.
So for example, so whether we
will be asked to.
What the graph is that
information we have right?
Otherwise, we will not even
know, right?
Like have we completed the
problem or not?
Let's say there are 20 nodes.
Your output gave you only 14
nodes.
Yeah.
You don't even know that if the
problem was complete or not,
this graph representation is
given to us.
OK, OK, it's not.
Yeah, someone was asking some in
exam or something.
Yeah.
For example, there will be asked
to use, uh Python or something,
so it'll be expected.
No, not at all.
I don't worry.
Yeah, in the return exams, there
will be no question which will
ask you to do Python.
It will only be pseudo codes
through local arts or explain or
My.
refute.
You know such type of questions
or some use case will be given
dual identify what you will do
there.
You know things like that,
we'll.
And the and we will be writing
on the pen and paper, right?
Not on the computer, Sir.
Or will be it will be online,
uh.
Both are available, yeah.
If there are some questions
where you feel you don't want
pen and paper, you just want to
type a small para, then you can
directly type it in the tool.
Or if there are any, you know
diagrams you want to write
Yeah.
something, explain, then you can
write it in a pen and paper and
attach that there.
So you'll have a a mock exam and
so on.
OK.
Did you already have it or?
K in my first time to me, are
you?
Yeah.
Did you already have a mock exam
guys, or not yet?
Not yet, Sir.
Right place, no.
OK.
No.
Yeah, before your exams you will
have it.
You will be given a chance to
take it.
Yeah.
See, your friends are telling.
It's already done, so check your
emails.
And for EC2, Sir?
You might have got, yeah.
Same for.
For EC2, yeah, yeah, it is the
same.
Easy to also OK.
Yeah.
Check your emails.
There might have been some links
on practice exams, so try to do
that before your exam.
Try to do that so that you're
comfortable on how the platform
looks and all that.
Yeah.
And these type of tools I will
provide you.
But as I told in the exams, you
cannot use these.
You know, tools, but while you
learn if you want to put
animations and all that, it will
be helpful.
Sending exam, there's no Python
code.
Something like working code and
all.
No, nothing.
It's honestly, yeah.
OK.
Thank you.
Yeah, only in your assignments
you are expected to use Python.
Your expected to give proper
code which can work.
We will test your code, whereas
in your exams actual exams mid
semester and final exams.
Nothing.
Yeah, you will have to only
write pseudo code.
For assignment, can we use any
language?
PARTHASARATHY.
Yeah.
No, you have to use only Python,
correct? Yeah.
But are there still solve?
So.
Sorry, we're actually we we.
Yeah, go ahead.
Yeah, a few chunk of the people,
you know you are are staying
outside India, you know, and we
are struggling in other ways
like you know there is no online
mode of exam and yeah.
No, there there is some
discussion going on.
So there was a form I believe,
which you all have filled right
that you are abroad and all
that, yeah.
Yes, yes and yes.
Yes, yes.
And there are lot of people who
are struggling on this.
Face it, you know, and we are
not getting a clear, you know
outcome that how we are going to
have the exam and literally we
are struggling in that ways.
So I will we have filled it out
and we will be sending the
message as well.
But I you know from bottom of my
heart to, you know, we are
No, no there is.
There is discussions. Yeah.
requesting this.
Yeah. Umm.
Yeah, yeah.
I have conveyed my part.
I have already conveyed this and
for people who are either
outside or maybe in the
different sector, or if you
know, for group of people who
are not in India, then something
Yeah.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
will be taken care.
It is gone all the way higher
up. Yeah.
That will be much helpful.
Yes, yes, that will be much
helpful.
So these decisions are not at my
level, it will be taken at, you
Yeah.
Yeah, I yeah, yeah.
know, say so, but it is already
in there.
Since the mode of exam. Yes.
Here.
Yeah, they are discussing it.
Yeah.
You will get a positive note.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
You will not have the exam on
the very same day.
Thank you.
Yeah, of course.
Yes, yes, yes.
Because, you know, it is still
not clear.
Because, you know, we have a one
week of time.
Yeah.
Yeah, because timing and all are
varying too much.
So definitely we will be
requesting to take consideration
Yeah.
Yeah, there are a couple of
options that has being weighed,
on that.
Thank you. PATHAK.
Yeah.
so that will be taken care here.
Umm yeah, thanks.
Thank you.
Thank you. Bye.
Cool.
OK, someone please share the
link to mock exam.
OK.
Yeah, that's there in your
emails, maximum number of inputs
we can consider for assignment.
Or any number.
Yeah, that is what is our
algorithm analysis, right?
All edge conditions.
All of those you should consider
your Python code will be
actually tested, meaning we will
run it and see for any given
input valid input.
Is it working or not?
I can even give invalid input,
so for invalid input you're
assignment code should first of
all recognize that these are
invalid inputs and it should
gracefully handle using try
catch block, yeah.
So can we have multiple set of
input or single set of input?
Each time single set.
Yeah, you cannot give hundreds
of input all at once.
OK.
Yeah.
One you will give, you'll run
it.
Then you want some other input.
You'll again give, and so on.
Yeah, that's right, SURENDRA.
Yeah, even if you gave
alphabetically and and expect
such things.
Yeah, I've known for all this.
So there might be questions
which are not solvable.
Yeah, I might still end up
giving that you tell that this
is not solvable.
I'll give you full marks.
Yeah.
So that is also a learning,
right?
You you know very well the
concept that, you know this
cannot be applied, right?
So such things I mean, not now
in the open book.
Let's see about all that.
Cool.
Let's get started.
Again, we have already know.
Been discussing for a long time.
So cool.
So graph we have completed right
all the techniques how to
represent it the traversals all
that.
So now we will go back to
another data structure which is
called binary search tree.
Yeah, it's called BST.
So what exactly is this? BST.
Yeah, just by the word.
Are you able to guess something?
Binary search tree.
So what data structure is this?
Yeah.
3.
Linklist store array.
Exactly.
It is a tree.
Yeah, it is a tree because the
name itself has tree and it also
has that word binary.
So then it has to be a binary
tree.
Yeah.
So it is a binary binary tree,
and if it is a binary tree as
guru says it is nonlinear.
Yeah, all this is clear now.
What does that search word?
What is this?
You know, something new will
differs from normal binary, so
we have already discussed
different representations in all
of them.
We did not impose any
restriction on the nodes data.
Did we any number any value can
be there in any node?
Yeah, we did not put any
restrictions there, but only one
thing we told is if it is a
binary tree, every internal node
can have Axum.
Two children.
That's all we told, but that two
children can be anything we did
not put any restriction there,
but now we are going to do that
as a result to search for an
element, we need to check both
in the left subtree and in the
right subtree.
Yeah, due to this, the worst
case complexity of search
operation in a binary tree is
big off.
Yeah.
Do you understand?
This slide is a normal binary
tree given to you.
I need to search for an element.
You never know where that is.
You start from the root, you
search all the directions left
and right, left and right, and
ultimately you might get it, or
you might not get it.
And the worst cases we go off
when you have inspected all the
nodes.
It can be improved.
This yes, by doing what?
By putting some constraints so
as the name suggests, the main
use of this representation is
for searching.
In this representation we impose
restriction on the kind of data
a node can contain.
As a result, it reduces the
worst case complexity to log in.
Yeah, but, but let's see if it
is really log in or not.
Yeah.
So what does this BST in a
binary search tree?
All the left sub tree elements
should be less than the root
data and all the right subtree
elements should be greater than
the root data.
This is called a binary search
tree property.
Note that this property should
be satisfied at every node in
the tree.
Very important guys, not at just
at the root.
At every level, every place this
property should hold good.
The left subtree of a node
contains only nodes with keys
less than the node key.
The right subtree of a node
contains nodes with greater than
right.
Both the left and right subtrees
must also be BST and so on.
Let's take this example.
As is root for root alone, if
you see all the elements to its
left will be smaller than that.
All the elements in the right
will be greater than that.
Many textbooks would depict that
BST cannot have duplicates,
right meaning equal to?
What if we know I have duplicate
numbers?
How do I put it?
They will not allow BST to have
duplicates in many real life
applications.
Also, we don't allow duplicates,
but there is still a
possibility.
Yeah, I would recommend you to
read CRS book and even in one of
my slides I'll show an example.
If you tweak this definition a
little, if you allow duplicate
then that'll come either to the
left or the right, right?
We will see when the time comes,
but in general BST will not
allow duplicates or equal to.
It is strictly all elements left
will have smaller and right will
be greater.
Is it clear?
Base all of you the BST
property.
Yeah.
Yes.
No, maybe I don't see any
responses.
But consider this tree.
First of all, is it a binary
tree?
If it is not a binary tree right
away, you will tell no, this is
not BS, because it's not even
binary.
So this is binary.
All of them have only two node,
three and four.
If you consider now 425, all of
them are smaller than this
seven, so it is in the left nine
is greater than seven.
So it isn't the right perfect,
but for 9 it is a leaf no
problem.
Leaves are no problem for this
internal node.
Two is smaller than four, so it
is in the left side.
Five is greater than four, so it
is in the right side, so this is
a valid BST.
What about this one?
Yeah, one is smaller than three,
so it is left no problem.
Six is greater than three no
problem, but two is a problem.
Two is smaller than three, but
it is coming to the right side
of three, so it is not a BST.
Right, so far, so good.
All of you.
What about these 618?
All of them are smaller than 10,
so it is coming to left side
131114.
All of them are greater than 10,
so it is having to write side.
Similarly for this 1311 is
smaller so it is in left 14 is
greater.
So it isn't right.
One is smaller than six and
eight is greater than six, so
all good.
So it is a BST, but for this one
right for this one.
Well, is greater than 10, but it
is coming to the left side of
10.
But there is a problem.
There's one more problem here.
At 99, is smaller than 10, but
it is coming to the right side.
So problem even if there is one
problem somewhere.
Yeah, you can immediately tell
that this is not a BST.
Yeah, so far, so good, all of
you.
Yes, no.
If a tree is given, Amit and
others, will you all be able to
figure out if it is a BST or
not?
But every internal node you will
check left side should be
smaller than that.
Right side should be greater
than that.
If this property is obeyed, then
it is a BST.
Otherwise it is not a BST.
As I told BST with duplicate
keys is also possible, but
you'll have to change the
definition itself a little.
Let X be a node in a binary
search tree.
If Y is a node in the left
subtree of X, then Y dot key is
less than or equal to X dot key.
If Y is a node in the right
subtree of X, then X dot key is
greater than or equal to X dot.
So the definition itself you are
including the equal to right?
So if you see here for six, all
these are smaller.
These are greater for this five.
There is another five here, but
by definition now this Y dot key
which is in the right side is
greater than or equal to this.
Why so now this is fine, so
explicitly if you modify the
definition to include duplicate
key then this is possible.
Otherwise, in general duplicates
is not allowed, yeah.
Tradition.
Others were discussing in the
chat.
Very good.
An inorder traversal of a binary
search tree will give us a
sorted output, right?
So if you have a tree like this,
this is a BST, correct one is
smaller than two, so it's left
four is greater than two.
It's in right.
All these three are smaller than
six.
These two are greater than six.
Perfect.
This is a BST, so now if you do
a in order traversal that is
124689 that is sorted.
Yeah.
So can you go to the previous
slide please?
Yeah.
In this one where five is
duplicated, the below 15 which
Correct.
is there left node we cannot
have at all right?
Because it will violate that
poor, we cannot have three.
We cannot have because it will
violate the above 15 which is
there left, right side, greater
than five.
No greater than we can have,
right?
We can have something like say.
Yeah, that's what I'm saying.
I mean left.
We cannot have anything.
Correct.
That should go here.
Yeah, that should go here.
Something like here.
I mean lift, lift, lift.
If you have modified the
definitions, no.
Childish blocked, right?
Let's take a number.
Yeah, let's take a number.
What number do you want to
insert now?
Yeah.
Do you want to insert 3?
I mean live child will be
blocked right below 5.
What?
The why will it be blocked?
Is there left check?
No.
Take a number.
Do you want to insert three or
what do you want to insert?
Or.
Said, what about the secondary?
Let's say 4.
The B tree.
Here also it's same no five is
there so five is in the right
side of this five.
But by definition you are
allowing this equal to, so it it
was fine, but it is still a BST,
right?
Five is greater than two, so
it's in right side 768 to all of
them are greater than two.
It's in the right side for 765
are smaller and this eight is
greater, but still this five is
in the right side of this file,
right?
By definition, this five can be
greater than or equal to this
five, so it's OK and here if you
see if you want to insert 4.
So for this smaller than six, so
it should come to the left side.
Four is smaller than this five,
so it should come to the left
side.
Four is greater than this too,
so it should come to this side.
This is wrong.
Or is it right, Vinay?
OK, got it.
Got it, Sir.
Yeah, got it.
Right.
Cool.
BHAT can be considered as binary
tree D.
Or is this not an?
It is an ADT right?
It is an abstract data type just
like stack or queue.
You are only creating it using
some properties, so it is an
ADT.
It says suppose uh in 3A, can
you please go back uh, if
Yeah.
available.
The five is written the Note 5.
Yeah.
If there is 4, if there is 4.
Uh-huh.
This one or this one the top
one?
Uh, no.
The above 1 level one.
This one.
OK here I change it to four, OK.
Uh, yeah, uh, it is full.
And I suppose again, the phone
will come, then it will go to.
This is the.
This is the tree.
Now suppose if four will come
again.
Correct.
Again.
So where it will go?
It will go in the left of my.
Go for a smaller than six so you
come to the left side.
Four is equal to 4, right?
So there is a problem now.
Yes.
Either you can put in left or in
right, because in both the side
you have now added this equal to
definition.
So either if you go to the left
side, you will go to two, four
is greater than two, so you will
put it here.
That is one way or the other way
you could have gone to five and
four is smaller than five.
So you would have food here.
Both of them are correct because
by definition you have included
that equal to in both the sides,
right?
OK.
OK.
The bold side, we can put. Uh.
Right.
Either you could have food here.
Yeah.
Here or here.
Some we want to insert a six in
a then a insert it into the left
Yeah.
of seven.
Or will I check with the five?
Yeah, it is either approach.
Either you could have had here.
Yeah, this is also correct.
Or you could have put here.
Yeah.
One of them you can choose, but
that is why again, 99% of BST
OK.
applications will not allow
duplicate.
Yeah, in even in a lot of books,
you might see that duplicate
will not be encouraged.
But if you still want to apply,
yeah, you can actually tweak the
definitions, but as you told
there are some ambiguities
someone might put it here.
Someone might put it here, but
both are correct because by
definition you have included
equal to.
Yeah, in our examples or in our
case is mostly will not use all
this.
Yeah.
We will not allow duplicates,
but I just wanted you to tell it
that it's still possible.
Yeah.
And your real life application
you're using some BST.
You have some streaming data
coming in.
There could be duplicates, so
you should not go with the
general crowd telling no BST
doesn't allow duplicate.
Yeah, if you change the
definition a little, you can
still accommodate it.
Yeah.
Is that clear, guys?
This is more like an edge
condition, yeah.
Cool is the sorted property
clear for all of you.
If there is a BST given to you
if you do a in order traversal,
you'll get the output as a
sorted 1.
Yeah.
Operations on BST.
What all can I do?
I can find some element in a BST
or I can find minimum.
I can find maximum in a BST or I
can insert some element.
I can delete something.
We'll have a quick look at
these.
I'll leave you free for the day.
Important notes on BST, yeah.
So this is all fine.
This is all about complexity,
but let's first take an example.
There is a tree given like this.
I want to search or.
I want to find the element for
very important you will always
start the search from the root
because this is a rooted tree.
This is not a graph, right?
So find operation is
straightforward in a BST.
Start with the root and keep
moving left or right using BST
property.
If the node we are searching is
the same as nodes, then we
return the current node, meaning
we have got it.
If the data is not present, we
will end up in a null link.
Let's start.
We want to search for 4/4 is
less than six, so you go to the
left side, right?
You reach to four is greater
than two, so you go to the right
side.
You got four for searches
successful.
So when you started here, 4 is
less than six.
So is there any way that four
can be there in the right side
of this tree, right side of six?
Can it be there?
I've already given.
No.
I've declared that this is a
BST, so if at all four is there,
it should be in the left side of
six.
It cannot be there in the right
side, so this whole part I am
not searching or in other words,
this is a very important concept
in computing called pruning.
I don't look at this at all
because I'm very confident if at
all.
Four is there.
It should be there in the left
side.
It cannot be there in the right
side and I completely ignore the
tree.
This could have been a very big
tree also right?
All of them could have had
children's right.
I'm completely ignoring that, so
that is the benefit of this.
Let's say I want to search for
4141 is greater than six.
So what am I pruning here?
Which side am I pruning?
Yeah.
They too.
Left side.
Steps.
Right side.
Let's say except for him Dev
set.
Silent.
Let's say pruning.
Which side am I pruning? Yeah.
File this whole side.
Say, let's say, let's say we
have PUNEET.
Yeah, we are pruning.
So for the one is greater than
six, I come here, 41 is greater
Let's see.
than nine, but nine doesn't have
a right child at all.
Right, so here it is.
Null nothing is there.
So I can declare right away here
telling that 41 is not there,
right?
So what is the complexity then
in all these cases at every node
Login.
I am discarding one side.
So this login, that is what
BSDCH promising is.
He's a very good guy, but he'll
be trace.
Yeah.
Can someone confirm if this is a
BST or not?
20 is greater than 10.
It's in right side, the T is
greater than 20.
It's in right side 40 is greater
than 30, it's on right side.
So this is a perfectly valid
BST.
I want to search you 41 is there
or not 41 is greater than 10 so
you have to write 41 is greater
than 20 you go to write 41 is
greater than 30 you go to write
41 is greater than 40 but there
is no right side.
So now you tell that 41 is not
there, but to tell 41 is not
there.
How many nodes did you traverse?
Order of you in this in this
case.
All no and.
Yeah.
So is the worst case complexity
of BST login or N if you tell
And.
log north.
This is the end.
If you tell log in, I can always
draw BHAT like this and prove
you that it is N.
So the St also bit readers, but
if you think deep about it, is
it a problem of the BST or is it
that structure of the tree like
this?
This is nothing like an array,
right?
Because only in one side you
have, you cannot prune anything.
Everything is there only in One
Direction.
This type of tree is called as a
skewed tree.
You can have either left skewed
when you have a tree going like
this, I mean right skewed or you
can have a left skewed like this
where only in one side the tree
is growing.
Yeah.
So this is a problem with the
structure.
Yeah, skewness is a problem.
If you have skewed Ness, a
skewed tree, is it a linear data
structure or a nonlinear data
structure?
If it is only going in One
Direction like this, then it is
Linear.
linear.
Then it is like an array, only
then complexity is nothing but
It's.
we go up.
Yeah, correct.
Right.
So you are not even having a
tree.
This is a tree, but this is like
there's also a tree, but if you
go deep into that concept only
in One Direction, it is growing.
So the link list will be just
one side, so this is a big off
then complexity.
So what is the crux of it?
BST is a good friend.
He somehow tried to help us.
He tried to get as a complexity
of log in which neither array
stack Q3 graph run of them were
able to give.
Somehow he gave a promising
concept that put all the smaller
ones to the left, greater ones
to the right.
In that way, you'll be able to
prune when you are searching one
side, so you'll get a complexity
of log in, but still this
notorious guys skewed tree
spoiled the complete concept, so
the BST complexity is still big
of north.
Great.
So how to tackle this?
That is for a later class.
That is what the scientists ABL
did.
Yeah, you learn about it later.
So for now finding, yeah.
So one thing.
Yeah.
Go ahead.
If we have a leaf on the skewed
tree also it is called as an as
Q3.
For example, we have 20.
We have something like 19.
OK, so where will so 19 is
greater than 10, so it will come
We will have it.
We will.
It will come, you know.
here 19 is smaller than 20.
Yeah, I think.
So it will come here, right?
Yeah, this is also called as a
skewed tree.
Yeah, this is also stupid
because in this side it's
already growing way too higher,
right?
If some other nodes are just
added here, then it is again
OK.
skewed only right?
Cool, thank.
So cuteness is just a concept.
It means you are three is
heavily loaded on One Direction.
Yeah, that is the case.
Then you can call it as as Q3.
So just for an and things like
in the article or like in there
any databases we are having
their binary tree indexes right
P3 yeah.
whenever we are, yeah.
Whenever we are inserting the
records, the one to three, the
Umm. Correct.
primary or something then first
it will be created as queue.
Retry right?
Yes, but internally it will
rearrange itself to be a big
tree.
OK.
Yeah, that's a different
concept.
There is something called as B
tree.
There is something called as B
plus tree, right?
All of them, but fundamentally
they all work on this principle
of BSD, but you'll understand
more about it once we learn AVL
and in all that, yeah, school is
inclined towards any One
Direction perfect.
If it's right side, then it's a
right skewed tree which left
side.
It's a left skewed tree.
How do you quickly search here
through to itself?
Is null return null because
there's nothing if the data that
you are looking for is less than
the root data.
Which side you should search?
Yeah.
Which side should so it's left
side right data is less so you
Looks like.
will search in the left side if
data is greater than root data,
you'll search in the right side.
So what type of an algorithm is
this?
Find is the method name again
and again you are using find but
you are altering this part
alone.
This action.
Perfect.
Yeah, this is recursion.
Where will be the minimum in a
BST.
Can someone quickly tell that?
Lived most.
Leftmost.
Yeah, left most leaf node
correct.
Lift.
So if you put this definition in
a BST, the minimum element is
the left most node, which does
not have a left child.
So in this BST you go to left
you go to left, four is the
leftmost guy who doesn't have a
left child.
So he's the minimum in this
whole tree, right?
So how will the code look like
play left of X is not equal to
null.
Keep going.
Ultimately, you will fail from
this while loop.
That is the answer, right?
Keep going in the left side.
Again, complexities big of yen.
Why?
Why is it then and not log in?
Yeah.
Cute dreams.
Skilled.
Exactly.
If you have a left skewed tree
like this, then this guy is the
minimum and you would have spent
big of yen to go there.
What about the maximum element
in a BST?
Where will that be?
The right most.
Right, right.
Drive most.
The right most node who doesn't
have a right child, correct this
Which might do it there.
one.
So 16 doesn't have a ichill, so
these the largest.
So right most node which does
not have a right child is the
largest until the right most
node doesn't have a right node.
Keep doing in a while loop.
Once you hit the while loop,
it's you know you cannot go
further.
That is answer again because of
skewness, we go forth is there
right complexity?
Cool.
Don't.
There is this very small concept
called in order predecessor and
in order successor.
Yeah.
What is this?
Yeah, let's take this particular
3.
So whatever I am highlighting,
can you comment about those
nodes relation with X?
Will there be greater than X or
will they be smaller than X?
Get at the next.
Greater than.
Whatever I greater than cool and
in the left side, all this will
Smaller.
be smaller than X.
Smaller than.
With that being said, if you
pick this node X for X, you can
find 2 words.
One is the predecessor of him.
One is the successor of him.
What are those?
Yeah, the predecessor
predecessor node.
Yeah.
What is that?
The predecessor node of this is
in the left side.
All of them are smaller, but in
that there will be a largest
way, correct.
We'll always be here.
The other in the left subtree of
X.
If you find the largest that is
called the predecessor of X.
Similarly, on the right side,
all the numbers are greater than
X that I already know, but among
all those numbers who are
greater than X, there will be a
smallest one right that is
called that he'll always be
here, and he's called the
successor of X.
Let's take this example for a 25
who is the predecessor.
Ring.
Smaller than 25 exactly among
them.
Yep.
20.
Good.
Who is the largest 20?
So he becomes the predecessor of
25, and in the right side all of
them are greater than 25.
But in that, who's the smallest
out of 403545444935?
35.
That guy becomes the successor
of 25 guys.
This concept clear what is
predecessor and successor.
Predecessor is the maximum value
in the left sub tree and
successor is the minimum in the
right subtree.
In normal English, also, if you
remember predecessor successor,
that is what it means right?
So 20 is preceding 25, so he's
the predecessor.
35 is greater than 25.
He's the first largest number
after 25, so he's the successor
of 25.
Will you might be like, why
suddenly this we will use this
sometime later.
That is why I also told this if
35 was in the place of 40 then
yeah, then things will change.
But just remember this concept.
This guy will be the successor.
This guy will be the predecessor
if you alter the nodes, of
course everything will change,
yeah.
Well, let's try to do some
insertions.
Yeah, insertion in a BST.
How do you do finding?
Is it clear for all of you find
the minimum, find the maximum
normal find?
Is it all clear and even is the
leftmost, which doesn't have a
left child.
Maximum is right most, which
doesn't have a right child
normal find.
You will keep pruning at every
decision node, but skewness
spoil the whole sport.
He made the complexity of big of
north.
Now let's learn the normal
insertion insert key an element
is there in a BST DNA at the
root.
Compare the element K with the
element at the current node.
If the value we want to insert
is less than the key of the
current node, go to the left.
Another way is go to the right,
if we reach a null then create a
node with the value we are
inserting and place it here.
Let's do it.
First thing first, is it a BST?
Real quick, is this a BST?
Yes, Sir.
Yes.
Yes, Sir.
You're.
OK, insert 35.
How do you do it?
35 is greater than 20, so go to
the right side.
Will compare from 20.
35 is smaller than 40, so go to
the left side.
Right.
35 is greater than 30, so we
should come to the right side,
It's.
Photo.
but 30 doesn't have a right
child.
So create a node, put 35 there,
add it to the right side of that
you have inserted 35
successfully.
So far so good.
Yes, no.
Insert seven.
Yes.
Yeah, this is already a VST 7 is
less than 20.
Go to the left side seven is
less than 10.
Go to the left side seven is
greater than six.
Go to the right side is already
a node.
Here 7 is less than 8, but eight
doesn't have a left child.
So create a node with seven as
its value.
Add him as the left child of
seven left child of eight.
Insert successful.
Insert the element 18.
Yeah.
Insert the element 18.
So when so one minute the 30 by
35 also can be inserted in on
Yeah, go ahead.
15 right said.
the right side of 15 and 8,
right?
Right away, start from the root
is 35 greater than 20.
Yes.
OK, OK.
So you cannot go to the left
completed.
OK. Yeah.
Yeah, the story always starts
from the root.
You're comparing their.
That is a decision point.
If 35 is greater than 20, there
is no way 35 can be in the left
child of 20, right?
Then the whole BSD property is
violated, right?
If 35 is here, 35 is greater
than 20, but it's in the left
child.
If you do that, this whole tree
will not be a BST anymore, so
don't do that.
So when we when we look into uh
time complexity for insertion so
in by two time will be in I mean
we need to shift in the.
Yeah.
If we implement through the
array, then we need to shift
each and every.
Uh ohh.
Element to the right side to the
subsequent index, right?
So it will be very, I mean
invite to like like it will be
ON complexity right?
Yeah.
Correct.
Because shifting will be taking
time.
But but it is helping you later,
right?
So when you want to search you
are able to prune something.
But yeah, you're right.
Yeah.
Or the simplest argument I can
make is this.
What if I have elements like
this skewness?
So I'll have to keep inserting
if I want to insert another
Yeah.
element, I'll have to traverse
all of them and insert it here.
So it's big of.
Inserting his cumbersome right?
Yeah.
Insertion is yeah, insertion is
cumbersome because every time
you are doing a check and then
you know going left or right and
Yeah.
doing all that but with the hope
that search will be beneficial.
But in this case, because of
that skewed Ness search also did
not become log N that is also N,
so insertion, deletion,
searching all of them became big
of north, which is fine.
OK.
But using this concept we will
create something better later.
Yeah, using AVL trees he will
promise us better complexity.
So that's how evolution happens,
right?
Initially we make mistakes, but
later if there is a better data
structure on top of this, it
uses these concepts.
So there is 18, yeah.
So, so didn't we St there won't
be ever such kind of scenario
where we are getting any such
number which we have to insert
in between.
Uh.
Yeah, there will never be a
case.
With with this person, yeah.
Yeah, always.
It'll go get added in the leaf.
You're right.
Would observation.
You cannot just randomly insert
somewhere here.
Yeah.
So what about 1818 is less than
20 go to the left, 18 is greater
than 10, go to the right, 18 is
greater than 15.
So hide in there.
Insertion.
Is it clear for all of you?
So I guess internal, so we won't
be able to add that element.
So wherever it is incomplete,
that is only the place we can
Correct.
So that position, just like your
heap, we can call it AZZZ is the
never do it.
appropriate position where it
should get inserted.
Yeah, we should find that Z and
then put him there.
Thanks.
So what if six is present below
8?
Then where will the seven go?
Where so 6 cannot be below 8.
If the below 8.
How can that be?
Somewhere here you mean or?
I'm ohh yeah.
OK, it should be less than, so
we can't repeat the six, right?
It can be duplicated.
Yeah, but, but as I told, that's
a very rare edge case only if
you are deciding to allow it.
But in general, if people are
talking about BST, it means
duplicates are not there.
OK.
Yeah, only when you allow that
case, this is valid.
Otherwise this is not valid.
Yeah.
So, so six, so six kind six can
go in the left of seven and also
Analysis.
Uh-huh.
Yeah, go ahead.
it can go in the right of two.
Correct.
That's right, but only in the
definition or question.
If it's told that you can allow
duplicate, yeah.
If five is to be inserted, no
problem right?
I use smaller than.
Let's clear all this.
You have taken several examples.
Five is less than 20, so go
here.
Five is less than 10 go here, 5
is less than six.
8 right of two.
Go here.
Yeah, that's right.
Put it here.
You're done.
Complexity because of N.
Yeah, I'll not go through the
whole story.
But you know why it is yen?
Because of that skewed Ness?
Yeah, cool.
That being said, I'll just
complete this slide.
We'll take this forward in the
next class instead.
All of you clear.
You will compare, left, right.
You'll go to the right place,
you'll insert him there.
Simple stuff.
There's a lot more exercises.
Practice them, keep even more
clear.
Deletion.
First of all, you'll have to
search for that number.
Do you agree I have BST?
I randomly tell you go delete
those, but several thousand
should be there so you will
perform a search if that number
what I told to delete is present
then you will delete if K is not
present return a message that
delete that element is not
possible.
But if that number is present,
then deletion involves 3 cases.
What I want to delete is a leaf
node, meaning it has no child.
If it is a leaf that is 1 case,
that is case one, case 2
whatever I want to delete has
one child that has exactly one
child.
Then it is case two.
What I want to delete has both
the children left and right.
Then it is case 3 for each of
the case there is a different
technique to delete them, yeah.
So what we will learn about all
the three cases in the next
class if it is case one, how do
you delete if it is case 2, how
do you delete?
If it is case 3, how do you
delete?
Yeah, and that will complete our
concept of BST.
Yeah.
Is it clear for all of you?
As usual, I'll upload the
slides.
Yes, Sir.
You can practice the problems
and we will take it forward from
Thank you.
here in the next class, yeah.
Or I have a question, do we have
a standard library for in Python
for this tree or we need to?
Yes, yes, there are plenty of
them.
Yeah, there are libraries, but
you will implement it from
scratch, if at all you have
assignment on BSD.
Uh, I would recommend not to use
those builtins and just using
plain linked list and so on.
Try to create it on your own.
Yeah, try to write.
Not for the exam in uh for
implement for in.
Of course, yeah, you can use it.
Yeah. Yeah.
OK.
In your employment or in your
office, and all you can directly
use those built-in libraries.
Yeah, they don't come by default
with Python.
OK.
As I told, there is a lot of
third party right just like
Yeah, that is my concern is
because are they maintained or
Numpy or pandas, correct?
not because I don't see any
standard library for praise.
Yeah.
Yeah, they they will not be
maintained as good as Python
because it's all created by
third party people.
But still there will be good
support because they're all open
source.
You can always contribute if
there's a bug, you can report,
it will be still maintained.
OK.
Thank you.
Yeah, notebook for BST.
Yes, we will upload that.
Yeah, but after completing after
completing all the concept,
we'll upload that.
Can there be a case for where we
have a subtree associated with
it?
Yeah, in all the cases, subtree
is associated.
Yeah, that is what we're talking
in all the cases sub trees are
there.
And then in the subtree you find
what you want to delete.
That is that case where you have
both children right, left and
right.
It could be a subtree in
themselves, so all that can be
there, so let's take it from
here.
We will complete the deletion
part alone and then we will go
to hashing and that will
complete your mid some potions
and the next class will be your
last class before your exams.
Yeah.
And I also keep you posted, so
I'm traveling to one of the
campuses, so I might I'm
reaching on next Saturday, but
let's see, maybe I will swap it
with.